thomas bonjour vous avez assisté à la
manifestation
que faut-il en retenir une manifestation
à l'appel des deux syndicats de
magistrats l'union syndicale des
magistrats le syndicat de la
magistrature c'est assez rare pour ne
pas dire inédit que ces deux
organisations syndicales fassent front
commun front commun donc pour protester
contre les prises de positions du garde
des sceaux eric dupond-moretti ils ont
appelé à un rassemblement à 13 heures
ici un rassemblement qui est désormais
terminée rassemblement ici donc devant
le tribunal de paris mais aussi devant
d'autres tribunaux sur le territoire
national il estime tout simplement qu
eric dupond-moretti attaque
l'institution judiciaire et deux
dossiers cristallise notamment les
critiques d'abord il ya l'ouverture
d'une enquête administrative contre
trois magistrats du parquet national
financier le pnf et pour ce fait le
garde des sceaux est accusé de conflit
d'intérêts par les magistrats qui
étaient présents ici et puis l'autre
sujet de discorde sont les critiques
d'eric dupond-moretti qui a dénoncé la
culture de l'entretoit au sein de
l'école nationale de la magistrature
écoutez katia dubreuil elle est
présidente du syndicat de la
magistrature justice qui a promis depuis
des années par les conditions dans
lesquelles travaillent les juges ou par
les réformes
ce ne sont pas les justiciables en moins
soit de droit sont de moins en moins
accès à la justice
donc ça va plus la justice décrédibilise
parce qu'elles n'arrivent pas à traiter
correctement les affaires alors que
c'est une condition essentielle en
démocratie de pouvoir traiter
correctement des affaires dans
lesquelles les droits des personnes sont
en jeu et donc aujourd'hui les
magistrats en ont assez pour vous
explique en fait c'est parce qu'ils
n'ont pas l'esprit du contradictoire que
les choses vont mal c'est parce qu'ils
n'ont pas l'esprit effectivement du
respect des droits de la défense
non ce sont des lois qui ont été votées
c'est la volonté du législateur d'avoir
modifié un certain nombre de choses lors
de ce rassemblement ici à paris le
député de la france insoumise ugo
bernalicis est venu apporter son soutien
et condamné ce qu'il perçoit comme une
nouvelle illustration de
l'instrumentalisation de la justice à
des fins politiques écouter le député la
france un soleil c'est important pour
nous parce que on combat et vous le
savez depuis nos perquisition mais pas
qu'eux aussi par un mouvement déjà les
jeunes une instrumentalisation politique
de la justice est là on est parfaitement
dans le cas de fumure d'une
instrumentalisation politique de la
justice par l'exécutif par le garde des
sceaux eric dupond-moretti pour des
intérêts particuliers les siens d'abord
et on peut aussi supposer que ce soit
pour d'autres intérêts il est donc
reproché à eric dupond-moretti
d'affaiblir l'autorité judiciaire et
finalement ne pas avoir vraiment pris la
mesure de sa fonction de garde des
sceaux les slogans lui était
particulièrement hostile ici lors de ce
rassemblement est de l'aveu des
magistrats présents il va être assez
compliqué de renouer un dialogue serein
avec le ministre parce qu'il nous
affirme que d'un certain côté la
confiance a été rompue
thomas mercier a beaucoup pour toutes
ces précisions